[موسيقى]
عندما أشعل الوحش ، أشعر نوعًا
ما كأنني أقود مركبة فضائية ، فأنت تعلم
أنها لا تزال مظلمة بالخارج ، تضغط على
زر واحد وتضيء السماء
هو أفضل مكتب لك في العالم
ننظر إليه على قمم مسطحة  كل صباح
ليس يومًا سيئًا
بقدر ما أحب أن أكون على
لوح التزلج الخاص بي في ذلك الوقت ما زلت
أستمتع بقيادة هذا الوحش
[الموسيقى]
الذي نلتقي به في الجزء السفلي من الجندول
ونتوجه إلى أول واحد في  صباحًا
في الساعة 6:30 نتوجه هنا إلى محطة الإرساء لدينا
مع وحش التاكو حسنًا
[موسيقى]
Tyrone I didn't steamboat لمدة 30 عامًا
لقد فتحت نصف المطاعم في
المدينة والعمل بالخارج
للجبال مثل ثلاثة  أنا فقط في
المطبخ لبضع ساعات يوميًا بسبب
ما فعلته في الغالب هناك ، أوه ، بعض
الأسئلة المضحكة مثل ، هل تترك
المطبخ هنا وأنت تقود القط الثلجي
بعيدًا ،
كلا ، كلا
[موسيقى]
نبيعها طوال الوقت  لذا
فالناس بالتأكيد فايكنغ ما
نرمي به بالتأكيد
[موسيقى]
لك